[Music]
from the studio who turned Luke and Han
into puke and gone and the director who
imagined Wolverine as a Brokedown shell
of his former self comes Hollywood's
latest reminder that time is the great
destroyer and we're all marching toward
irrelevance and bitter disappointment
shocking no one showed up for this one
isn't it let me die please kill me now
let me die please I am so
depressed Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny Indiana Jones is back and since
everyone hated Crystal skull's happy
ending he's
sad his wife left him his students don't
want to sleep with him anymore and he's
the only man alive who misses shy Abu I
told me he was going to die but when
he's visited by his beloved goddaughter
whose name never came up before I'm her
Godfather Harrison Ford will be whisked
off for one less trip around the world
of elder
abuse stop the man is in his
80s he belongs in a museum flea bag
Waller Bridge joins the franchise as
Helen a Shaw a real Disney executive
type the only thing worth believing in
ever is Cash she's charming and
seductive presumably take the other
character's word for it come here I want
to show you something
go I thought maybe you returned because
you loved me who so clearly set up to be
the next Indie they put a map of Indiana
on her forehead she'll spawn with her
own boy servant Teddy this literal Straw
Hat pirate as Jin's answer to Short
Round who's less about put downs and
more about putting Nazis down for good
and who learns how to fly from the movie
School of hey good for you kid
maybe you'll also win an Oscar in 38
years and Harrison will be there there
to oh never mind when you've already
done Nazis Cults Nazis and Aliens it's
Nazi time again they're working with
Mason a clueless CIA agent from the
shallow end of the deep State your
Associates killed three American
civilians and blew up a nationally
televised
parade clayber who keeps his actor
streak going as the most forgettable
part of your favorite franchise the
Wolfenstein boss you have to take out to
get the blue key card and vol
mads mikkelson's thirdd magic Nazi he's
more obsessed with World War II than
your dad and this Monday morning Ferb
wants to kill Hitler for all the wrong
reasons I saw every mistake every
blunder and I would correct them all I
say let him try he's the only German
alive with bad time management skills
214 BC you got the wrong War gain a new
appreciation for Steven Spielberg as you
watch director James mangold's cover
band version that uses Cutting Edge Tech
to make Harrison Ford look like a
melting wax figure of himself brin's in
rubble the fur is in hiding still candy
AES that voice though huh and has him
Forest Gump his way through some decent
action set pieces until the ending
brings the Fable dial of Destiny back to
ancient Greece so that Archimedes can
invent the dial of Destiny wait not only
is that a paradox but it's another Indie
movie where the same thing happens if he
never does anything don't look very keep
your eyes shut
except for a few more dead people I
guess
sorry my friend was just murdered so
enjoy a film that's remarkably similar
to your own father it's familiar just
going in a museum heels they look like
snakes no they don't where it doesn't
it here probably on its second marriage
and good for a few short bursts of
enthusiasm but talking big picture here
has no nothing new to offer and just
wants to be left alone to relive the
past
Helen get on the
plane I'll be all right hey maybe it is
time to start coming up with new movie
Heroes after all what do you say
[Music]
Boomers never great just check
it
starring welcome to the past my bedtime
The 40-Year-Old version Destiny's Child
Tapo rapaz a rocket scientist getting
into right-wing politics concerning bad
pit and my slacks CIA Dr Jones the other
one now you're thinking of Aristotle
that's Archimedes different guy p in BS
that's so Ravenwood I hate and cold
Cox
[Music]
wrinkled in
time I don't believe in magic wombat
what you witness the Ark of the Covenant
melt everyone's face you got brainwashed
by the spirit of KH you drank from the
Holy Grail explored an alien spaceship
you believe in magic did you know
Harrison Ford has the most onscreen
relationships with women who are at
least 15 years younger than him congrats
har we crunch the numbers on the age
dynamics of every movie romance in an
all new episode of by the Numbers
spoiler alert keep James Bond 500 yard
away from a school at all times click
the box in the right to learn
why if life gives you lives make
margaritas all the girls are in love
with me I'm a teen age labotomy the day
epic voice guy read your comment was the
most important day of your life but for
me it was
Tuesday